and that's why i hope to god one day we
cross paths so that i can perhaps be the
first person you've ever met to look you
in the eye and tell you i don't give a
damn about your pronouns
i will use whatever words i want to use
i will refer to you
however i want to if you could believe
it
i will call you anything i want to
and there's not a single thing you could
do about it
because you have no power
over me anyway
[Music]
for our daily cancellation today we turn
to the huffington post which for one
thing uh still exists that's the first
bit of news and the second is an
editorial on the site which has been
making the rounds online over the past
week or so it's written by somebody
named kelsey smoot who's a man i believe
a bit of a shot in the dark i'm not sure
but
he provides us with this bio
kelsey they them theirs is a phd
candidate in american studies their work
and writings explore the process of
identity formation at the nexus of race
gender and sexuality they are a cultural
and gender theorist a writer and
advocate and a poet having grown up by
coastal and spending the majority of
their adult life in a state of
transience they drew from their eclectic
life experiences both deep fear and
great optimism regarding what people are
capable of
now should give you a pretty good idea
about where this is headed uh though i
must acknowledge some gratitude to
kelsey for exploring the nexus of race
gender and sexuality very few people
have the vision and courage to really
dive in and study the intersection of
race gender and sexuality when i say
very few people i mean you know it's
only him and every other college student
in the western world
i mean students in china are all
becoming math geniuses and rocket
scientists our students are all getting
their phds in queer theory
all that to say we certainly needed one
more person to think and talk about race
gender and sexuality so i'm grateful he
was up to the task and he clearly
applied all of this expertise while
writing the huffpo article in question
titled
if you think my pronouns are optional
we can't keep being friends
now i'm tempted here to simply say
okay great bye
but that would make this segment a
little bit too short so we'll trudge on
he wrote
lately i've been embroiled in what feels
like constant conversations about
pronouns the wrong ones the right ones
the preferred ones hint that third
category is defunct
yes please update your rulebook the term
preferred pronouns which has been shoved
down your throat relentlessly is now
defunct not only defunct but offensive
the very people who invented the term
and demanded that you use it are now
demanding that you not use it because
it's offensive they've suddenly decided
why is preferred pronoun offensive well
presumably because the qualifier
preferred doesn't carry the weight that
they want it to it makes the pronoun
sound optional
but as a title the piece declares
pronouns are not optional they are
utterly necessary
if you don't use somebody's pronouns
you'll you'll kill them they will die
right there on the spot they'll shrivel
up and melt away like the wicked witch
pronouns are no mere preference they are
necessities like food water oxygen
pronouns are the very air they breathe
this is the claim anyway and it puts
into context the rest of what we're
going to read here continuing
as a non-binary trans person who uses
they them there's pronouns as my terms
of address i suppose i should be
celebrating this influx of discourse on
the proper usage of pronouns truthfully
i'm exhausted
okay we're going to leave aside the fact
that non-binary trans makes no sense i
mean these labels individually don't
really make sense but combined they
somehow make even less than zero sense
also note how kelsey declares himself to
be exhausted
common theme on the lgbt left you
remember that college student last week
who said he was exhausted because i was
giving a speech on campus
people who've never exerted themselves
who have lived coddled lives of unending
comfort who've never even attempted to
achieve anything of significance are
somehow exhausted
not that i doubt their exhaustion by any
means i fully believe that it's
exhausting to go through life so utterly
self-absorbed
to think that everything revolves around
you to constantly be on the lookout for
slights and offenses to be offended all
the time by everything and everyone
everywhere
this is extremely exhausting of that i
have no doubt
indeed this is one of the reasons i
could never be a raging narcissist i
just don't have the energy for it
continuing
in the six years since i have come out
i've witnessed the concept of pronoun
inclusivity shift from fundamentally
martian to hotly contested on the macro
level pronouns have become a cultural
battlefield an email garnish a token
signifier of righteousness for
organizations who want to rebrand
themselves as politically savvy and
inclusive he's right about that part
personally within the several of my
closest relationships the fact that i
require ungendered pronouns when
referring to me in the third person has
become the source of deep strain and
disappointment i feel duped by some of
the positive reactions from my friends
and loved ones when i initially came out
as trans mask
non-binary
in retrospect that was the easy part i
was the only one changing in the year
since i've come to find that i'm in
constant competition with my past
for a while i flinched when i was
misgendered but said nothing then i
began giving gentle reminders followed
by long-winded overtures of
understanding i felt guilty and
embarrassed
and made sure to emphasize emphasize
that effort was all that mattered to me
recently though i've begun pushing back
you'll have to do better is my new
refrain
now of course the proper response to
somebody who says you'll have to do
better regarding the pronouns would be
words to the effect of
oh yeah well you'll have to kiss my ass
you smug little [ __ ]
but unfortunately kelsey has not been
given the gift of that sort of honesty
instead those closest to him have
apparently tried to accommodate his
demands and even apologize profusely for
the times they slip up and accidentally
use proper grammar
that's not good enough kelsey says he
demands absolute perfect compliance from
everyone
100 of the time
or else he'll stop associating with them
which of course sounds more like a
promise than a threat to me
but reading a bit more here he says
as i think more critically about these
conversations
i feel regret about the moments where
and i have avoided asking the hard
questions that cut clear through the
facade of language the resulting
friction from these interactions has has
had negative consequences in my
relationships
i feel myself withdrawing from people i
love avoiding interactions that might
lead to misgendering and shrinking in
conversations that once felt safe and
enjoyable
inversely i've been told that spending
time with me feels more cumbersome now
shocking
in addition to long-standing
relationships new connections are often
marked with a similar tension regarding
my pronouns
the idea of having to lose some of the
people closest to me the folks who have
helped to shape me the person i am
is devastating however i consider having
access to me my time and my company to
be a gift not a given for anyone in my
sphere
i'm clear my inherent worth as a person
despite all the ways in which society at
large devalues me
to be frank this process of change
requires concerted effort to be franker
i think that trans and non-binary people
are worth the effort
well if i could be frank myself kelsey
allow me to say this
no
you are not worth the effort
at all
i mean your unbridled untamed unwielding
narcissism
unyielding and unwieldy narcissism has
turned you into a burden a strain on
everyone you know
you're not nearly smart or interesting
enough to make dealing with you and your
nonsense worth that kind of effort
you're an irritating tedious boar who
compounds the problem by also being
psychotically self-centered
but i'm grateful at least
that you have so convincingly
illustrated and proven a point that i've
made many times in the past which is
that this whole preferred pronoun thing
is nothing more than passive aggressive
manipulation a power play
by attention-starved egomaniacs like
yourself
you want to be affirmed all right but
you want to be affirmed as the center of
the universe the main character in this
production called life
you demand to be affirmed as the central
figure in everybody else's lives
you can't simply be around somebody talk
to them spend time with them you need to
be constantly reminded and you need them
to constantly remind themselves
that you are better and superior and
more important and more interesting
that's what the pronoun game is all
about
and that's why i hope to god one day we
cross paths so that i can perhaps be the
first person you've ever met to look you
in the eye and tell you i don't give a
damn about your pronouns
i will use whatever words i want to use
i will refer to you
however i want to
if you could believe it
i will call you anything i want to
and there's not a single thing you could
do about it
because you have no power
over me anyway
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content